did the CDC work with private companies
to influence a censorship of dissent
about vaccines
um you know that topic is one that is
under litigation in the court so I will
not be speaking to that
recently meta CEO Mark Zuckerberg said
that during the covid-19 pandemic
The Establishment kind of waffled a
bunch of facts and then asked for a
bunch of things to be censored that in
retrospect ended up being more debatable
or true did the CDC work with meta or I
like to call it Facebook still to censor
or otherwise alter any post here's what
I can tell you the most important thing
that has gotten out us out of this
pandemic I think is our vaccine and how
well they work and how safe and it was
really important that the American
people understand how well they work and
how safe I understand it but in terms of
the communications that is again
something that I'm not going to speak to
because it is currently entered you're
not going to answer the question it is
currently under Court litigation